nothing has signified the changing of
the guards so much as this
the signing of the covert stimulus
package a massive
1.9 trillion dollars dwarfing
any other rescue plan in modern times
thank you all appreciate it later in his
first
prime time televised address to the
nation the president said the deal which
will pump federal cash
into an anemic economy will help the
country
rebuilt a year ago were hit with a virus
that was met with silence and spread
unchecked
denials for days weeks then months
that led to more deaths more infections
more stress and more loneliness
america is clearly entering a new phase
in its fight against covid 19.
the economy is maybe the battlefield but
alongside the spending
vaccinations will be key in his speech
he directed states to offer jabs to all
adults
by may the first i said i intended to
get a hundred million shots in people's
arms in my first hundred days in
office tonight i can say we're not
going to meet that goal we're going to
beat that goal
by july the 4th there's a good chance
you
your families and friends will be able
to get together in your backyard or in
your neighborhood
and have a cookout at a barbecue and
celebrate independence day
i want to go back to work and i want to
be able to move around and this public
service announcement has also hit the
airwaves
ex-presidents and first ladies joining
the fight
urging people to come forward although
a more recent leader was conspicuously
absent
the response joe biden is now selling to
the american
people is extraordinary in its scale
but this is an extraordinary emergency
the human cost in lives and livelihoods
on the nation
is truly staggering more than half a
million americans dead
and an economy that's been decimated
one year on though and the pressure to
open up the country is growing
in texas they've already dropped their
masks and there is a semblance of
normality
but the question is is all of this too
much too
soon when the virus is still circulating
widely
alex rossi sky news washington